[Musique]
merci Philippe B merci beaucoup de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la mange
membre du groupe les républicains on va
bien sûr commencer en parlant de ce
texte immigration et après le rejet à
l'Assemblée l'exécutif a donc choisi de
passer par la CMP commission mixte
paritaire députés et sénateurs devront
donc trouver un accord sur la base du
texte du Sénat est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron
a choisi la meilleure option pour vous
mais c'est même la possible à quoi
aurait servi de renvoyer le texte au
Sénat qui s'est déjà prononcé très
clairement et donc l'étape suivante
après le vote de l'Assemblée nationale
sur le rejet du texte c'est la
commission mix paritaire il aurait pu
retirer aussi le texte mais il faut
unetion envisable il faut absolument
sortir des atermoiments nous avons
besoin et c'est un c'est pas un ultra
qui vous parle c'est un modéré nous
avons besoin d'un texte de rupture en
matière de contrôle desmigration
pourquoi c'est très simple nous avons à
la fois une aggravation de la pression
migratoire et une dégradation de nos
capacités
d'intégration si vous regardez les
chiffres mais sur longue durée c'est pas
la peine de se prononcer sur l'année
dernière et la précédente la France
avait délivré 3 millions 500000 visas en
1800000 10 ans plus tôt elle a délivré
270000 titres de séjour en 21 170000 en
2007 il y a eu 36000 demandes d'asile en
2010 120000 en 2021 60 % des demandeurs
d'asile sont déboutés seulement 19000
étrangers sont éloignés de la France par
an il y a une situation qui est
aujourd'hui une situation d'extrême
tension nous avons connu tous les
atermoims possibles cette année
j'inscris le texte je le retire je le
rinscris je le retire nous avons vu un
ministre qui soutient la version
exigeante volontaire du Sénat et qui la
laisse complètement vidée de toute
substance par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale il est temps que
le gouvernement affirme un cap clair et
le suivent avec constance il est temps
d'arriver à ce texte de rupture qui est
un texte respectueux de l'État de droit
mais qui veut vraiment de manière
radicale changer notre approche de la
politique migratoire alors pour qu'un
accord soit trouvé il va falloir on s'en
doute que chacun fasse des compromis
quel compromis la majorité sénatoriale
est-elle prête à faire qu'est-ce qu'il
faut lâcher selon vous non la charge de
la preuve n'est tout de même pas sur la
majorité sénatoriale la charge de la
preuve est sous le gouvernement veut-il
oui ou non aboutir à ce texte de rupture
que le ministre de l'Intérieur avait
soutenu au Sénat avant de l'abandonner à
l'Assemblée nationale prés
Dansette il ser il sera pas présent vous
serez face aux députés notamment à Sacha
Houlier qui est opposé à la version
sénatoriale le gouvernement est en lien
étroit permanent constant 24h sur 24
avec les représentants de la minorité
des députés qui le soutient car il n'y a
pas de majorité nous l'avons encore vu
et les défaillances des membres de ce
cette coalition qui soutient le
gouvernement mais qui est minoritaire
n'ont même pas été présent pour tous
pour soutenir la version pourtant
édulcoré de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons un
texte ce texte est un bon texte qu'
vient de nous dire qu'il ne convient pas
et à ce moment-là et bien il n'y aura
tout simplement pas de réforme de
l'immigration mais ils vous le disent
qu' convient pas ils veulent pas de ce
que vous avez fait de la me par exemple
ils veulent un rétablissement de l'aide
médicale d'État il veulent pas de l'aide
médicale d'urgence est-ce que est-ce que
làdus vous êtes monsieur Darmanin a
soutenu le texte du Sénat mais il a
aussi soutenu avant même qu'il soit
discuté qu'il ferait sien le texte du
Sénat et il capitule en race campagne
devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale de qui dépendent
les députés de la minoritéés pridenti à
l'Assemblée nationale du président de la
République qu'il fasse preuve d'un peu
d'autorité si le sujet est important il
a bien s le faire pour la réforme des
retraites il en réalité je vais vous
dire ce que je pense profondément il
n'attache pas d'importance réelle à
cette réforme il ne se donne pas les
moyens de la faire aboutir il faut il
veut l'échec de cette réforme pour vous
Emmanuel Macron il ne se donne pas les
moyens de la faire aboutir il c'est quoi
les moyens c'est faire pression sur les
majorit il faut aller au bout de la
démarche il y a un chemin possible il
faut l'emprunter ce chemin est
raisonnable mais il fait preuve de
volontarisme alors
allons-y dans son dans son intervention
20h de TF1 avanth soir Gérald haranin il
a eu des mots très dures à l'endroit DLR
il a parlé d'alliance des contraires et
il dit que vous êtes la béquille du
rassemblement national ça fait mal à
tous les électeurs de droite et du
centre de voir ce parti se perdre
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Gérald
haranin on peut verser dans la politique
politicienne ça n'est pas la manière
dont il faut s'y prendre pour grandir la
politique je vais vous dire franchement
il n'y a pas d'alliance entre les
contraires il y a le en même temps qui
pollue la politique française depuis
trop d'années euh il s'agit pas d'une
motion de censure nous n'avons pas dit
nous allons gouverner ensemble les uns
et les autres nous avons juste dit pour
des raisons différentes nous sommes
hostile au texte de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale qui a vidé
de sa substance le texte du séat mais
sur l'lr est-ce qu'ils ont eu parce
qu'ils étaient divisés les républicains
à l'Assemblée si vous vous étiez députés
vous auriez voter cette motion de rejet
mais comment voulez-vous qu'un groupe
politique qui porte le texte du Sénat
approuve le texte de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale il y a
juste un minimum de cohérence politique
attendre il faut pas flotter il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut on veut le texte du
Sénat est-ce que je suis assez clair ah
bah là c'est clair pour Emmanuel Macron
il a redit hier soir la dissolution
n'est pas une option pour vous elle
est la dissolution et le moyen ultime de
faire arbitrer par les Français une
difficulté reprenons les chose par le
début le président de la République a
été élu pour présider il n'a pas été élu
pour gouverner la preuve il n'a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
pourtant il a formé un gouvernement qui
lui est entièrement subordonné et il
essae vaille que vaille de tenir sur ses
bases mais son assise politique pour
gouverner est très faible s'il arrive à
une situation d'impasse alors oui il
sera peut-être acculé à prendre ce type
de décision mais je je ne lui
recommanderai pas de le faire car il a
d'autres voies possibles pour faire
aboutir ses réformes et je le lui dis
tout simplement pour l'immigration qui
est un enjeu majeur de cohésion
nationale qui est un enjeu majeur pour
que nos modes de vie nos lois la
primauté de la loi de la République sur
toute normes inspiré par la religion
toutes ces règles doivent pouvoir
s'imposer et il a les moyens de le faire
car il peut s'appuyer sur la volonté du
Sénat on va continuer à parler
immigration puisque hier était inscrit à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat un texte des
républicains visant à modifier la
Constitution pour permettre entre autres
un référendum sur l'immigration mais la
majorité sénatoriale s'est divisée les
républicains ont retiré leur texes on
parle de tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Steve
[Musique]
Jourdain Steve bonjour oui bonjouran
bonjour monsieur le sénateurour on va
parler d'un événement du coup passé
quasi inaperçu lundi les républicains
ont retiré leurs proposition de loi
constitutionnel sur l'immigration oui
c'est un texte qui aurait dû être étudié
hier soir au Sénat je m'étais préparé un
peu pour le cas j'urais d vous raconter
ce matin la manière par laquelle la
droite sénatoriale souitait réviser
notre Constitution pour permettre de
déroger au droits européens en matière
d'immigration mais le patron DLR en a
décidé autrement il a retiré sa
proposition loi au dernier moment mais
selon lui ce texte n'est pas enterré
écoutez Bruno
rotill ce texte demeure ce texte demeure
mais il est hors de question aujourd'hui
de faire un texte au rab je pense que la
politique elle crève des faux semblants
voilà ça n aucun sens d'avoir un texte
en réalité amputé de ces deux principaux
articles amputé par qui et que prévoyait
ce texte par la commission des lois le
groupe Union centriste qui a tiqué sur
deux mesures phares de ce texte
l'extension du champ du référendum à
l'immigration et au droit à la
nationalité au droit de la nationalité
pardon et la possibilité de déroger aux
droits européens en matière
d'immigration sur ces deux points c'est
nietette pour Hervé Marseille Hervé
Marseille qui est le président du groupe
Union centriste et qui compte 56
sénateurs on va l'écouter les conditions
étaient pas réunies pour pouvoir
discuter de ce
texte Bruno retaillot a préféré le
retirer là aussi il y a pas d'urgence il
y a les points sur lesquels nous étions
d'accord d'autres sur les lesquels nous
divergions on parlait de référendum on
parlait bon comme c'est un sujet qui est
un peu dépassé on peut on peut vouloir
un un référendum mais le sujet a été
clos par le Président de la République
parce que ça supposerait une révision de
la Constitution qui n'est pas
d'actualité bon Philippa à part vous à
part leslr personne n voulait vraiment
de ce texte il a été pourtant adopté en
commission des lois maisors de ces de de
mesur il comporte d'excellentes choses
par exemple il est écrit à l'article 1er
de ce projet de révision
constitutionnelle nul ne peut se
prévaloir de sa croyance ou de ses
origines pour obtenir qu'il soit dérogé
en sa faveur à la règle commune très
important c'est un texte que j'ai
présenté commission des lois dès 2015
qui a été adopté par le Sénat en
2021 et auquel nous tenons comme à la
prunelle de nos yeux mais celui-là vous
l'avez pas voté vous l'avez pas voté
vous l'avez pas signé pardon ceex si
nous avons voté ce texte non mais celui
qui a été retiré vous l'z vous l'avez
pas vous ne faites pas partie des
signataire vous l'avez pas signé
pourquoi vous l'avez pas signé je n'ai
pas signé ce texte tout simplement parce
que je n'en suis pas l'auteur mais pour
autant a un très grand
j'en
approuve les principaux éléments de mon
point de vue et je vous en ai cité un
qui ne fait pas un pli et qui a déjà
recueilli une très large majorité au
Sénat je vous signale d'autres éléments
très importants dans ce texte et nous
remettrons l'ouvrage sur le métier et
nous trouverons donc il est enterré vous
êtes d'accord avec Bruno ro ce texte
n'est pas enterré bien sûr que non nous
nous donnons le temps de le faire
cheminer la cause est entendue nous
sommes concentrés sur la loi pour la
maîtrise des flux migratoires c'est le
débat politique du jour nous n'ouvrons
pas tous les fronts en même temps mais
nous ne renonçons certainement pas à
faire progresser ce projet de révision
constitutionnelle qui comporte aussi la
possibilité pour le Parlement de voter
chaque année des quotas d'immigration la
possibilité que les demandes d'asile
soient par principe déposé à l'étranger
l'affirmation selon laquelle il faut une
assimilation à la société française pour
pouvoir être naturalisé ça nécessite de
réviser notre Constitution tout ça tous
ces éléments en effet nécessite compte
tenu d'un certain nombre de
jurisprudence d'affirmer dans le texte
même de la Constitution ces principes et
donc c'est nécessaire au fond une loi de
rupture pour le contrôle des flux
migratoires ne serait pas suffisante
pour aller au bout de notre démarche
avec précaution avec le souci de
l'équilibre cel va de soi mais aussi
avec détermination c'est un enjeu de
cohésion nationale qui divisé la
majorité sénatoriale c'est pas les
points que vous nous cité c'est la
question du référendum sur l'immigration
et surtout de la primuté du droit
national sur le droit européen est-ce
que vous étiez d'accord avec ces points
alors ce sont deux sujets pour lesquels
il y a eu au sein de la commission des
lois un débat qui n'est pas clos en ce
qui me concerne j'ai toujours été très
prudent sur l'extension du référendum
mais enfin ça n'est pas interdit non
plus en 1980 et en 2008 sous des
présidents de la République qui était
Jacques Chirac et Nicolas Sarkozi nous
avons élargi le champ du référendum et
donc il n'y a pas de sujet tabou on peut
y réfléchir quant à la primauté du droit
international et européen sur le droit
national je crois qu'elle doit continuer
à s'imposer mais il doit être possible
quand l'identité constitutionnelle de la
France est en cause par une
interprétation des stipulations d'un
traité ou des dispositions d'une
directive européenne par une un
découpage un peu chirurgical de faire en
sorte que cette identité
constitutionnelle de la France l'emporte
et donc de créer une procédure cette
procédure n'est pas encore aboutie mais
la piste qui est ouverte est une piste
qu'il faut continuer à explorer c'est
pas une sorte de brexit c'est ce que dit
le sénateur Philippe boncarer il dit que
cette primuté affirmer la primuté du
droit national sur le droit euréen c'est
une manière de de faire un frexit il ne
s'agit pas d'affirmer la primuté du
droit national sur le droit européen
mais de dire que par exception quand une
stipulation d'un traité ou une
disposition d'une directive porte
atteinte à l'identité constitutionnelle
de la France qui est une notion que le
Conseil constitutionnel a fait émerger
pour défendre le principe de laïcité par
exemple et bien dans ce cas-là par
exception on doit pouvoir dire ah non là
la règle nationale va l'emporter et ça
ne doit pas être systé que et il nous
faut trouver la bonne procédure et bien
et bien la ciseler et la rédiger je suis
prêt à y contribuer et si certains
partis en 2027 arrivai au pouvoir et
étaient moins respectueux de cette
identité constitutionnelle telle que
vous la définissez il y a pas un risque
selon vous la garantie c'est tout de
même que c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui se prononcera sur le
point de savoir si un point relève ou
non de l'identité constitutionnelle de
la France moi j'ai confiance dans le
Conseil constitutionnel ça a été
compliqué de trouver un accord avec les
centrises sur le texte immigration là on
voit c'est compliqué aussi est-ce que la
majorité sénatoriale est en train de se
fissurer la majorité sénatoriale au
contraire a adopté le texte sur
l'immigration il est normal qu'entre les
groupes de la majorité il y ait la
recherche d'un accord et cet accord est
généralement trouvé nous y parvenons
aujourd'hui nous y parviendrons demain
et nous sommes même prêts à élargir
encore le champ des consensus que nous
recherchons au sein de l'assemblée que
constitue le Sénat jusqu'à tous ceux qui
voudront dans le souci de l'intérêt
public rejoindre des positions que nous
affirmons mais c'est qui c'est horizon
c'est Renaissance on va recevoir Françis
patri le président du Sénat il a 212
voix la majorité sénatoriale c'est 189
nous avvons
expérimenter une un élargissement de
l'assise de la majorité sénatoriale
merci Steve à tout à l'heure
pour parler pour parler nous allons
parler nous allons on va parler
immigration évidemment par d'immigration
et de la suite de cette CMP qu'on attend
tous maintenant exactement ce sera à
suivre dans le club on va parler d'un
autre texte philiba c'est le texte qui
inscrit l'IVG dans la Constitution il a
été présenté hier en conseil des
ministres c'est la formulation du Sénat
qui a été retenue ou presque on va y
revenir formulation que vous avait
largement inspiré la liberté la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté garantie à la femme
d'avoir recours à une IVG c'est ce que
dit le texte final Éric Dupont morti
estime que cette formulation permettra
de faire converger les positions de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat c'est
votre
avis c'est un point de
départ c'est peut-être pas le point
d'arrivé pour vous dire les choses
clairement cette révision
constitutionnelle n'est pas absolument
nécessaire et cela pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que la liberté de la femme
de mettre fin à sa grossesse a déjà reçu
une valeur constitutionnelle c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel qui lui a donné
en France et cela depuis maintenant 22
ans c'était une décision du 27 juin 2001
le président du Conseil constitutionnel
n'était pas un dangereux gauchiste
c'était yvgena grand résistant grand
Gauliste madame veille siégeit au sein
du Conseil constitutionnel lorsque cette
décision a été prise ainsi que par
exemple madame Peltier qui était
l'ancienne ministre de Valérie
giscardestin de la condition féminine et
bien cette décision aujourd'hui fait que
la garantie constitutionnelle existe
déjà par ailleurs nous savons bien qu'il
n'y a pas en France un seul parti
politique qui met en cause l'IVG mais
juste pour qu'on comprenne bien Philipp
est-ce que vous la voterez cette
formulation telle qu'elle a été
présentée hier si vous me laissez le
temps d'exposer mes arguments j'allais
tout naturellement venir à la
conclusion donc ça n'est pas
indispensable mais effectivement vous
assurez votre maison contre l'incendie
ça n'est pas parce que vous pensez que
vous avez des raisons de craindre un
incendie pour demain et donc je sais que
beaucoup de Français attendent de
français et de
française attendent cette inscription
constitutionnelle alors maintenant les
débat
c'est soit vous la refusez par principe
ça n'est pas ma
position soit vous l'acceptez dans son
principe mais alors vous voulez veiller
au respect de l'équilibre de la voie
veille c'est ma position qu'est-ce que
c'est que l'équilibre de la loi veille
c'est liberté de la femme qui l'emporte
pendant les premières semaines de la
gestation mais protection de l'enfant à
naître qui l'emporte après les premières
semaine de la gestation je suis pour la
reconnaissance d'une liberté encadrée
pas pour la reconnaissance d'un droit
illimité une sorte de droit absolu de
droit opposable comme le droit au
logement par exemp que pour entraîner la
formulation T est retenue
et je vois que vous m'avez bien
suivi au fond il y avait une version de
la France insoumise voté par l'Assemblée
nationale cette version je l'ai
absolument rejeté avec le mot droit
parce que elle créait une sorte de droit
opposable devant les tribunaux et sans
limite un droit absolu une liberté
totale ça n'est pas l'équilibre de la
loi V et j'ai donc proposé au Sénat une
contreproposition qui respecte
strictement ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a décidé qui lui-même
respecte l'équilibre a droit mais le mot
liberté
et je vois que le texte adopté hier
reprend bien cette notion de liberté
dont la loi fixe les conditions mais
croit judicieux d'ajouter qu'il s'agit
d'une liberté garantie mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire garantie ça veut dire
qu'on rentre dans un droit opposable
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut tout et son
contraire moi je ne peux pas concilier
le texte de la France insoumise avec le
texte du Sénat et il semblerait que ce
soit le souhait du gouvernement alors
nous allons débattre moi j'aborde cette
question vous le savez de manière très
ouverte mais je n'accepterai pas
n'importe quoi on parle de l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution mais c'est
pas n'importe quelle inscription donc
vous ne voterez pas cette formulation si
on vous suit bien vous reviendrez à
votre formulation le Parlement a bien le
droit de délibérer des textes et
éventuellement de les modifier sinon
nous ne servons à rien mais moi je
voudrais qu'on serve à quelque chose on
va aller voir l'actualité dans votre
département pour terminer on vaou trouve
Chris Mel marchand rédacteur en chef
adjoint de la Presse de la Manche
bonjour Chris Mel merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Chris Mel vous intéressez-vous
au nucléaire avec notamment ces projets
de petit réacteur
oui parce qu'on a des élus Normands dont
le président de la région qui viennent
d'écrire au président de la République
ENF le but é de se positionner sur
l'accueil de ce premier réacteur
nucléaire de petite taille que compte
développer la la France à l'horizon 2030
alors la Normandie et en particulier la
Manche dont vous êtes le sénateur
Monsieur B sont déjà des territoires à
forte identité nucléaire et sachant
qu'il y a déjà de de nouveaux projets
comme le Pr de Flamanville qui va
démarrer normalement 2024 les 2 de pli
également la piscine d'entreposage de de
combustible usé à l'AG qui sont c'est
des projets qui sont déjà enclenché
alors est-ce est-ce qu'il faut continuer
à valoriser cette énergie sur le sur le
sol normand voilà ma question fait débat
c'est une reconnaissance de nos
savoir-faire de nos expériences nous
avons les ingénieurs les techniciens les
opérateurs euh et nous savons comment
faire euh d'une manière générale au au
si je me limite à la manche mais la
question porte sur toute la Normandie
nous sommes une terre d'énergie parce
que nous avons aussi une usine de
fabrication de Pal d'éolienne en mer
pour doter de systèm français ou plutôt
construit en France euh nos nouveaux
champs d'éolienne en mer et nous allons
expérimenter avec les chantiers
maritimes de Normandie les hydroliènes
en mer au rat Blanchard c'est dans le
côantin les courants sous-marins les
plus puissants d'e europeope et on va
produire à terme je l'espère
l'équivalent de l'électricité d'une
centrale nucléaire donc nous sommes une
terre d'énergie d'énergie propre
d'énergie qui ne contribu pas au
réchauffement climatique d'énergie sûre
avec un grand respect pour toutes les
prescriptions de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et nous allons nous avons
toutes les raisons de faire valoir cet
atout pour le développement de notre
territoire et donc je soutiens
pleinement les initiatives du président
de la région Normandie dans ce domaine
chrisel vous avez une question sur
Flamanville
oui alors la C de Flamanville se déroule
demain on attend beaucoup de
d'information à ce sujet notamment sur
le Pr puisque les essais viennent de les
ultimes vientent de se terminer est-ce
que vous avez encore un des doutes sur
ce réacteur de 3e génération ou est-ce
que est-ce qu'il faut absolument
l'enclencher le plus rapidement possible
la notion de rapidité s'agissant de le
Pr de
flamandville mériterait d'être
approfondi je crois qu'on s'est donné au
contraire tout le temps nécessaire pour
s'assurer de la totale sécurité de ce
nouveau réacteur beaucoup plus
performant que que les précédents
c'était en quelque sorte un prototype
c'est la première fois qu'on
construisait un tel réacteur en France
j'espère que pour l'avenir on saura
profiter de l'expérience de flamandville
pour pouvoir du premier coup réussir
l'installation d'autres réacteurs avec
une dépense qui n'explosera pas et une
maîtrise de la technologie qui permettra
à l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire de de
donner son blancin à la construction des
nouveaux réacteurs cette expérience nous
sera utile et nous serons heureux à
postériori d'avoir respecté toutes les
étapes et d'avoir suivi toutes les
prescriptions qui nous ont été imposé en
matière de sûreté nucléaire parce que
c'est le prix à payer la sûreté
nucléaire pour pouvoir développer cette
forme d'énergie qui est tellement
respectueuse de l'écologie que même
Greta tenberg a dit il y a quelques mois
qu'elle lui était favorable chrismel un
petit mot de votre une
oui alors on ouvre sur sur l'ultra
drroite dans le dans le département
alors c'est un phénomène assez nouveau
on a eu avec on a eu avec un
rassemblement d'un cruscule d'ultra
drroite à la suite d'un viol assez
barbare à Cherbourg et très récemment
des tags islamophomes sur la la mosquée
de Cherbourg alors je sais pas si vous
avez le temps d'en parler un petit peu
mais je sais pas comment vous analysez
ce phénomène particulièrement nouveau
pour la manche je me suis indigné et
tout d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux euh
de ces tags euh sur euh les lieux de
culte le lieu de culte musulman à
Cherbourg qui se trouve être représenté
par un imam très respectueux d'ailleurs
des lois de notre République quant à
l'ultra drroite euh ne considérons pas
que quelques
individus égarés constituent un
mouvement de fond il faut bien sûr être
être vigilant mais il faut pas non plus
accorder trop d'importance à quelques
individus isolés merci Chris Mel
marchand merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on a vu votre une et merci Philippe
B d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demure